pj les jaunes ont réussi et c'était les
premiers à le faire c'est pas les
syndicats qui l'avait fait ont réussi à
faire reculer macron qui a quand même
lâché 10 milliards donc c'était c'était
une première donc effectivement c'est en
mettant la pression sur les politiques
n'est aussi sonné sur les dirigeants
qu'on obtient des acquis sociaux et moi
là je pense qu'on est dans une phase
alors le faire parce qu'on voit déjà
tous les rapports qui ressort au faire
travailler plus les gens revenir sur les
congés une partie des congés payés les
vacances etc
là il va falloir que mais que le
salariat ou clés ou que même délaissé
tiennent le rapport de force
maintenant sur la question de la
réussite sociale de l'ascenseur social
et qu'effectivement le discours des
libéraux c'est de dire que quand on veut
on peut
c'est donc toute une question est
finalement une question de choix
personnel s'ils ont choisi les bonnes
études si on choisit le bon secteur
si on choisit de travailler beaucoup on
a une chance de réussir mais c'est une
fable en réalité c'est une fable parce
que vous avez derrière une capitale
culturelle le capital social et les
statistiques le montrent aujourd'hui
c'est à dire contre un enfant d'ouvrier
vous avez de fortes chances de ne pas
faire de longues études et quand vous
êtes un enfant de cadre vous avez plus
de chance de faire des très longues
études
pourquoi parce que le système est fait
parce qu'ils sont les dominants voiliers
et donc c'est très rare de voir des gens
qui ont une forte ascension sociale et
on va les mettre en avant pour dire
regardez à venir et encres à 6 existe
des gens qui oublient ça existe mais
globalement les là-dessus là globalement
ce que l'on voit c'est que quand on est
fils d'ouvrier on a plus de chances
d'être ouvrier que quand on est fils de
cadre ou ou fils de je ne sais je ne
sais pas quel autre métier est ce qu'on
appellerait un métier qualifié et ben on
a plus de chances d'avoir le même le
même type de poste donc il ya clairement
des freins donc aujourd'hui porté un
débat uniquement sur l'égalité des
chances c'est un débat qui est pour moi
trop limité il faut aussi qu'il y ait
une égalité de résultats c'est ça
aujourd'hui et donc pour qu'il y ait
cette égalité de résultats mais il va
falloir faire comme pour les acquis
sociaux que certains les premiers
concernés les délaissés exerce une
pression politique ou au mieux place
quelqu'un au pouvoir qu'ils ont choisie
qui servira leurs causes qui servira pas
la cause des reins 5
son
[Musique]